bist du weiter nach links ah nee ja gut
so ist perfekt nein Leute Ich bin's
Laser Luca ich bin wieder da am Start
nicht lachen Challenge mit Sandra und
Luca schon wieder dabei zu sein schöne
Challenge mag ich auch total gern die
Regeln keiner darf lachen
das war's
[Musik]
das ist nicht das respektvoll aber ich
finde wenn
wir sowohl 25
oh mein Gott
am meisten feiere ich ihre Crocs an den
Ohren was ihr hattet als Ohrringe
[Applaus]
als übrigens fragt warum ich so nass oh
sehe und so fertig ich wurde vielleicht
gerade von dieser Dame hier die ganze
Zeit in eine Wasserschale rein gedrückt
egal
[Musik]
das könntest du eigentlich sagen
[Applaus]
hast du nicht so was gespielt früher
doch ich habe das immer im Sitzen
gespielt egal ist Malle Alter
genau
aber der macht das in real life und das
ist so lustig das jetzt am Anfang direkt
als ähm weibliche Persönlichkeiten
angesprochen ich hoffe das ist in ihn
jetzt nicht zu nahe gekommen
[Musik]
ist ich habe diskriminiert ja okay
heftig heftiger Kerl Frederik
[Musik]
ey was hältst du denn
eigentlich deutsch ist in Ordnung
[Musik]
ich liebe solche Videos
also wirklich Spaß
[Musik]
Leute
8,8 Stunden gefüllt in einem Unterricht
sag ich mal im Herbst guck mal Leute bei
mir war immer erste Zeit oder kommt
Pause nach Hause ich war nicht mal da
weil ich habe gewonnen
aber die ist ja quasi wie du wir wollten
nur den Ball testen
[Musik]
Köln
diese Scheiße es gibt einen sehr schönen
Spruch Freunde wenn du hässlich bist so
wie ich aber einen schönen Charakter
hast dann bist du trotzdem Bruder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die hat fünf Millionen Likes auf dieses
Video denn Großeltern oder irgendwelche
Senioren einfach
gar nicht wissen was sie machen immer
ein paar at-esch
ja das war es jetzt mit dem Video lass
doch gerne mal nichts da Ciao
ach so an alle die Fragen wegen Podcast
wir äußern uns am Sonntag zu